I think a lot of guys they try to be
pronatalist right and they're like I'm
just going to go out there and have a
lot of kids right but pronatalism is
about culture if I just go out there and
I have a lot of kids and I don't treat
my wife like a queen if my daughters
don't grow up wanting to be moms because
of the way they see their mom live then
I have failed failed and if I treat my
wife like failed and my sons see that
then they're going to treat their wife
that way and their daughters yes and
this is what pronatalism about it's
about rethinking as a society what it
means to be married to somebody
to
sacrifice because that's what I owe all
of this to is her because she's given up
so much for me I like this guy